Korea has four distinct seasons: spring, summer, fall and winter.
Spring and fall are very pleasant.
The weather is nice and the flowers are beautiful.
When the leaves change, many people go hiking or go for a walk in the park...
...just to enjoy the pretty colors.
The only problem I have with those two seasons is that they are too short.
It seems that the summer and the winter last longer than the spring and the fall.
It is a shame that the mild seasons go by quickly...
...and the intense seasons stay with us longer.
One of the many things that I don't like about the Korean summer...
...is the heat wave that almost always comes after the monsoon season.
The weather forecast even warns against people getting frustrated because of the humidity...
...and gives advice to take it easy.
It's too bad that the weather can cause such stress.
But when it gets really hard to concentrate on anything...
...and it feels like you're going out of your mind,...
...you know it's time to take a break, pack up and get away.